rückblick auf den wahlkampf ich habe
mich schon etwas gewundert dass im
wahlkampf kaum eine rolle gespielt hat
die frage womit verdienen wir in zukunft
in unserer volkswirtschaft das geld was
wir dringend brauchen um alle
öffentlichen aufgaben und ausgaben
seriös finanzieren zu können ich habe
immer auch mit guten argumenten gehört
wir müssen mehr tun für bildung für
forschung für rente für soziales für
pflege ich dachte jetzt gleich kommt wie
stärken wir die wirtschaftliche
leistungsfähigkeit unseres landes wie
stärken wie die einnahmenseite kam aber
nicht es sind zwei ganz fundamentale
gegensätzliche positionen was schafft
wohlstand es ist die umverteilen und
natürlich immer von oben nach unten oder
ist es fleiß ist es die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist es die
innovationskraft eigentlich müssten auch
die größten anhänger der umverteilung
wissen du kannst nur das umverteilen was
vorher im land erwirtschaftet worden ist
und wie wir das schaffen wie debatte
wünsche ich mir heraus war ja also ich
stimme ihnen in allem was sie gesagt
haben komplett zu dieser wahlkampf ein
ausgaben wahlkampf nie darum eigentlich
mal zu überlegen wie muss das was da an
ausgaben propagiert wird finanziert
werden und vor allem wie kann man
möglicherweise bei den ausgaben auch ein
bisschen mal auf die bremse treten also
ich bewundere die deutschen steuerzahler
muss ich sagen das sind ja die größten
masochisten eigentlich mittlerweile des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sie lange
wird eigentlich nur genau man muss sich
beschimpfen lassen als steuerzahler aber
eher ein dank der politiker gegenüber
steuert hahn hat es noch nie gegeben und
ich glaube was sie ansprechen ist
vollkommen richtig es muss so etwas
geben wie einen wahlprogramme check
lässt sich das was beispielsweise die
linkspartei die grünen aber auch die
union im wahlkampf propagiert und
verspricht lässt sich das eigentlich
finanzieren oder nicht die niederländer
haben so etwas da gibt's ein institut
das berechnet seit zwei jahrzehnten
jedes wahlprogramm durch und sagt ist
plausibel ist nicht plausibel lässt sich
finanzieren lässt sich nicht das
brauchen wir ja auch jahre kennen diese
rechnung ja zumindest insofern dass
vielleicht dann die steuerprogramme der
parteien durchgegangen werden und dann
heißt es ja also nach dem programm würde
dem staatshaushalt würden so und so viel
mehr milliarden oder auch weniger
einkommen aber das ist natürlich immer
ein wahnsinnig multidimensionales system
weil es dann nicht mit einrechnet das
jahr dann zahlt man vielleicht weniger
steuern das kurbelt die wirtschaft auch
wiederum an usw also es gibt also viele
unsicherheiten in seiner rechnung aber
ich habe schon auch den eindruck gehabt
denn den harburg formuliert dass man
über das ausgeben von geld sehr sehr
freigiebig spricht und über die
notwendigkeit die wirtschaft zu stärken
wenn überhaupt dann immer nur so ein
bisschen verschämt und klammheimlich und
fenstern und mich fragen geht wo soll
das geld herkommen naja dann ist ein
vorschlag der durchaus auf dem tisch lag
eben schlicht ergreifend mehr schulden
machen schuldenbremse aufweisen ja das
ist ja einen weg und ich glaube dass
politiker inzwischen in gewisser weise
enthemmt sind denn sie wissen ja es ist
auf jeden fall genug geld da nämlich
unsere also ich glaube dass bei allen
bekundungen zum trotz und mein sozusagen
letzter großer ritter in dieser
situation ist dann christian lindner der
sagt keine steuererhöhungen und nur mit
diesem blick sehe ich ihn jetzt durch
die koalitions sondierungen dann tappen
in den nächsten wochen da wünsche ich
viel spaß denn es wird doch nur darum
gehen wie man die steuererhöhungen und
nicht das ist eine steuererhöhung heißt
also es wird irgendwo muss er geld
herkommen es weiß ja jeder mensch wir
haben also wenn man ja ja ja
unternehmen sein nein ich würde sagen
wir brauchen mehr geld also wir haben
wird auch dieses jahr
also glaubt irgendeiner am tisch mit den
kauf finanzieren oder es wird schlicht
ausgegeben ich glaube dass wirklich
überzeugen dass der staat schlechter
unternehmer ist und wenn ich mir einen
haben brauner ist sogar dass die
ausgaben besser kontrolliert werden
müssen und das glaube ich würde ich auch
an christian ender stelle wirklich bei
den verhandlungen auf den tisch bringen
mal sagen wie ist denn die korona
rechnung wurde was ausgegeben weil wenn
man steuererhöhungen fordert finde ich
muss der staat erst mal zeigen ich habe
das geld was rein kann gut ausgegeben
nur dann kann man verlangen dass mehr
geld und es waren ja alles so dringlich
werden die summen um die es da geht
dreistellige milliardenbeträge die da
jetzt sozusagen weg sind denn die müssen
irgendwo herkommen also außer meine
gesamte wirtschafts logik als aus dem
kleinen karo eines mini haus hält das
ist durcheinander irgendwoher musste es
ja kommen und meine prognose ist völlig
klar es wird von uns kommen ist nur die
frage wie es aber klar es ist ein
bisschen so wenn du dir das beispiel in
gewisser weise natürlich auch wenn die
acht neue oder sommer zehn neue autos
kauft dann sagst du auch das geld für
diese autos das muss irgendwo herkommen
die frage ist natürlich müssen es so
große autos seien und dass die
luxusausstattung sein brauchst du auch
den fuchsschwanz am spiegel oder geht
noch ein bisschen kleiner diese frage
muss manchmal ob ich dann immer dass sie
zu meinem auto das ist die menge und den
fuchsschwanz aber
die sechs autos oder 18 okay aber den
fuchsschwanz
ihre tiere sich ihre seine zeit brauchen
wir mehr geld oder muss der staat besser
wirtschaften
das eine schließt das andere nicht aus
was mich nur wundert ist wenn zum
beispiel ist ja als ein klassisches
beispiel wir brauchen mehr geld für die
klassische infrastruktur strasse schiene
wasserwege für die digitale
infrastruktur für den wohnungsbau der
bund steuert salat die abrichtung für
2009/10 vorgelegt von 16 bundesländern
haben 13 die zur verfügung stehenden
mitteln nicht aufgebraucht weil es an
baurecht fehlt weil soll weil klagen
eingereicht werden also das hängt ja
alles und bei den atemberaubenden zahlen
pomona hilfspaketen national und
europäisch das wird in aussicht gestellt
wir müssen den zwei drei jahren mal
fragen was davon tatsächlich abgeflossen
ist der staat hat ja noch im moment
glück weil wir ja für die kredite die
wir aufnehmen so gut wie keine zinsen
mehr an also wenn wir die zinsbelastung
noch hätten bei der mir gehen jetzt
knapp drei millionen neuverschuldung
hoch 2,6 2,7 dann hätte ja selbst ein
wirtschaftlich starkes land wie
deutschland erhebliche probleme denn
nehmen ja ohnehin immer ungefähr ist ole
gunnar 200 milliarden schulden auf im
jahr warum man für 200 milliarden
schulden tilgen warum weil wir dafür 34
prozent bezahlt haben und für die neuen
schulden nichts mehr das hilft dem staat
im moment tilgen muss so und so aber wir
sehen ja immer wieder wie in die eine
tasche gegriffen wird um es dann mit der
anderen hand wieder neu zu verteilen
bestes beispiel ist das thema
grunderwerbsteuern das können die
bundesländer zwar regeln je nachdem kann
man seinen eigenen satz festlegen die
derzeit zwischen drei und sechseinhalb
prozent je nach bundesland immer auf den
kaufpreis obendrauf das heißt die länder
schrauben ist nach oben um dann aber das
ist natürlich dann bunt aber eine eigen
heim zulage zu beschließen das heißt ich
mache das kaufen einer immobilie teurer
als start und sagen mensch ist so teuer
dass können sich jetzt immer weniger
leute leisten also nämlich geld und gibt
es denjenigen die sich dann mobile nicht
mehr leisten können weil sie vorher der
staat mit verteuert hat das ist doch
schizophren
kommt noch hinzu dass es mal eine höhere
steuer gehabt ich glaub dir war sechs
oder sieben prozent mit unzähligen
ausnahme vorschriften und da hat der
stadt gesagt die ausnahme weil jeder
versucht hat und eine ausnahmeklausel zu
kommen die ausnahmen streichen wir und
senken die steuer ab dann haben wir die
ausnahmen gestrichen aber die steuer
erhöht dieser widerspruch lebt in uns
wir wollen also als ganze bauen angeht
das soll energetisch sein das soll
modern sein wir verteuern das bauen aber
die mieten sollen deswegen die steigen
es ist vieles widersprüchlich das stimmt
[Musik]